let's go next to our caller from the six
one nine area code if we can whose
calling today from six one nine does
that mean that's you okay perfect I was
calling because I was on I had a
question about that you can see monitor
demonic to take the monetization of
YouTube D monetization yes it's
difficult to one decision okay so um are
we and then can we agree that the reason
why mainstream media doesn't talk about
certain topics is because they don't
want to spend their appetizers um would
that be a fair assessment I think as a
general principle there's no doubt that
there there is influence in terms of
what you do and don't see on corporate
media based on the whims of advertisers
sure yeah okay perfect so why would it
be any different for YouTube what it
would tell me more about what you mean
okay so if this mainstream media doesn't
talk about their topics because they
don't want to send their advertisers why
wouldn't you to feel the same way like
okay these leftists are offending
corporations that are advertising with
us right shut them down oh yeah yeah no
you're completely right I mean the
that's the whole problem YouTube started
out as one thing and now it's basically
becoming through these monetization
policies it's basically becoming just
like corporate media and in fact it's
mostly legacy corporate media channels
that have a youtube presence that are
being propped up by YouTube I completely
agree it's becoming exactly the reason
it would be different is because YouTube
started as something very different but
listen it was bought by Google it's
become huge it's influenced in many of
the same ways that corporate media is so
you're completely right it's basically
become like corporate media so so my
what's the what what do we do moving
forward because I I saw the idea of a
union YouTube Union being propped up but
it kind of got shut down by other
youtubers so I'm just concerned like so
what what should we do looking forward
the best thing to do is fund the shows
that you like directly because that
makes the
not have to worry about what it is
that's happening with monetization you'd
YouTube did do one thing
YouTube YouTube CEO recently said in a
list of all sorts of stuff much of which
is not great she said it's really
important for people to be able to
upload whatever they want to YouTube
assuming it's not illegal so that's
great as long as you can upload whatever
you want to YouTube if your audience is
funding you directly and you don't have
to rely on YouTube's monetization that's
the best path forward to be quite honest
and it's the most reliable one as well
um alright thank you David alright
appreciate the phone call thank you